wie ein löwe ich hoffe die mähne weht
ihr der bahn wird da so laut ich raus
und deutsches trio wir müssen jetzt gar
nicht krass in die kamera reden weil wir
uns im migros haben
das heißt ich kann mich auch ihr
geheimnis so geschockt dass eine drehung
machen alle zusammen
zu einer neuen freude jacobs fortschritt
gemacht
hallo leute wie geht es euch wir haben
sich von mir in zehn jahren so das
papier geht es wie akut vom band rolle
die bin ich die schreibt das ist nie gut
gibt ich bin hier dabei einfach manchmal
hallo ich freue mich natürlich jeder
hier zu sein und dementsprechend kann
ich euch einfach nur sagen leute es geht
jetzt los was waren denn eure songs
gehört dabei wir haben eine top 5
ausgesucht und in dieser top 5 haben wir
uns die meisten übergreifenden songs von
einem artist genommen und dazu machen
wir heute unsere cocktails wer hätte das
gedacht was war es denn bei dir kelly
bei mir war
ja ich habe gemeint sind der tm schien
damit allerdings unter den hammer kommen
hat mich solide über die letzten zwei
bis drei jahren begleitet wird nur
besser aus gehauen zu einfach geil da
muss man einfach dem unten auf je
gebannt wenn man ihre innern gibt keine
endgültiges man heiratet rammstein heute
mit dem fred perry politik hier und sagt
ich hab nur rammstein gehört letztes
jahr ist es keine nazi marke ich bin
kein nazi keine nazis commerce leben
clarke duncan und du es versteht sich
von selbst dass niemand wird verletzt
für ein paar kröten in deiner leder
bauchtaschen auf platz eins bei mir
tatsächlich ps 2 und 3 und 4 ist apache
und auf platz sechs und zehn also papa
joe morgan ist silvester und dafür
sollten wir ordentlich auf ein gutes
jahr anstoßen man sagt ja immer gerne
das ist ja nicht nur wir hatten tolles
jahr meiner fucking augenblick so also
trikot ist ein teurer champagner aus
die fertige album das sie sind ja schon
nicht auf
und jetzt meine frage technik das teils
durch nicht sagen und man ist nicht als
spaß aber 48 euro gekostet und die
können uns weiter richtig und das ist
auch unser hauptzutat die wir brauchen
denn es ist ein tag zum feiern
vielleicht lassen wir kennen die auch
doch die tasche aufmachen ich bin bereit
dafür dass ich wirklich aber nicht ging
es geht alles gut
jetzt habe ich angst wegen gemacht
denk an deinen song ich habe angst dass
es hier von rapid und dann
und schon ganz oft auch nach 2020 auch
euch ein frohes neues jahr
viel glück und gesundheit und geld so
wichtig wusstet ihr dass jeder
champagner aus champagner kommt unsere
sammlung stunde aufgestellt unsere
sachen for change anschauen
hallo ich muss noch den zweiten treffer
als elektrisch kontinents hallo ich habe
ein paar sachen vorbereitet ich habe mir
zum einen dieses wunderbare glas gekauft
weil das sehr an das rammstein verändert
deswegen sieht das schon mal sehr hell
wie aus muss ich sagen aber sie hätten
aber damit habe ich mir sehr viel mühe
gegeben wo ich kann das heute sagen ich
habe kein obst dabei das waren sich
jetzt fast gut neu beginnen dafür habe
ich eine kombination an sachen die man
heute machen wird für diesen trinken
macht lieber nennt macht den hat weißt
du wer die letzten male gewonnen hat die
[Musik]
band und chor welcher dosierung von
sodass
und das in kohle was denn dazu habe ich
dann noch was ganz wichtig ist ein
bisschen rum ich hab's einen bucher
heute auch noch als nebenkläger ich habe
wodka und ginger beer
ganz ehrlich ich glaube freude hat
einfach nur den einkauf für seine
nächste party über dich
finanzierungslage auch und das ist
glaube ich schon mir also ich habe den
main
die magnifico kräfte chinesen rum ist
hier richtig ekelhaft rektoren in jail
sondern aus wieso spiritus oder der fans
damit abermals nur ins modische absolut
finde ich auch stachelbeeren geguckt hat
limetten und irgendwann und mich
natürlich und ich bin mir nicht ganz
sicher was mein glas sein wird aber das
ist ein guter kandidat
du weißt schon dass etwas mit dem alter
zu tun haben ja und du hast irgendwas
mit indianer vorher gesagt ja was ist
davon geht sondern die haben uns
gesprochen michael kauffeld ich hab in
bern und double dip und eine 7 dann noch
kuschelig hört der kann noch glitzern
außerdem habe ich den coolsten krieg und
mit meiner deko wird ich alle weg wie
cool
und vielleicht noch das war die eine
kreative zweiten zusammengenommen oder
sieben schwimmen darin alles gute
kollegen diesen satz zu sagen das hat
sie gedacht dass meine dass zufolge hat
euch bewerben das war die letzte folge
drei kätzchen ballern für immer und ewig
denn ich habe keinen bock mehr auf
diesen scheiß türken die dort spiele
beginnen
wir fangen jetzt alle an so das war
jetzt an ihr seid immobilien motiviert
mich nie dafür meine zutaten
ich habe euch ich habe gar nichts gesagt
was ihr gemacht habe ich mich zu
unterschätzen
diese champagner forscher auch zu machen
da ich über meine zutaten lustig zu
machen und ich habe nichts getan außer
respektvoll sein aussprechen zu lassen
und alles zu akzeptieren was ihrem
brennt ja ja ja der brend und wurde
dritter
jetzt also soweit hätte ich nicht
gedacht wurde das gespräch mit den
stetig weiter seine zutaten gescheitert
war weil ich weiß dass deiner lecker
schmecken wird weil du so viele
zuschauer aus welche teile ist eure
lieblings zeile und warum
da möchte ich schon mal nichts dazu
äußern
das habe ich einfach abgeholt
[Musik]
ich glaube bei mir mal warte aus dem
song briefen hat sich mal den genauen
wortlaut im kopf aber in einem ferrari
testarossa wie man den warum ich mit
dieses mal auch einfach die sound vom
sachen wörtern worten wir müssen sehr
gut aufteilen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die position
[Musik]
das hat die getrunken während ihres
albums wenn sie das gemeistert
in zwei wochen die das betrunken jemand
der 400 millionen euro offen geld an der
hose 40 dollar 50 dollar und dann noch
in amerika selbst aber das volk kreis
vechta ich denke mal bei so leuten so
weinert 100 und simon hunt sich weises
revealed that need for government
regulation hallo und herzlich willkommen
beharrte teurer großen kunst und bastel
show
also los geht's mit artete das nicht zu
teuer das muss ich auch sagen
eines tages im teletubbie land eine
halbe sachen rücken eine posse cocktails
altar
o
also seid jetzt mal ehrlich wie findet
ihr die präsentation nicht beschützen
wollen ein erstes mal ein strohhalm
genau die eigentlich gekauft wolltest du
gar nicht mehr haben was geht was
jetzt sind wir kurz einfach und dann ist
einfach nur blut raus gekommen
das liegt jetzt hier vielleicht einfach
party und botox wusste ich dann alles
auf ich kann ihm haben
das ist jetzt nicht diese weise handelt
also ich bin eigentlich soweit fertig
muss halt erst was machen wenn ihr fels
schmidt
euro wir kommen da hätten wir uns
richtig ein hinter dem ohr gewidmet die
aber endlich einen draufgemacht haben
sich betrunken sind auto gefallen
du bist aber auch fertig jetzt oder weil
du hast ja schon würfel drin ich trete
mit zwei kandidaten hatte vor seinem
durchbruch hatte nach seinem durchbruch
der hat sich doch nicht geändert da
bleibt doch gleich das nicht war ein
erster für mich gut also jetzt jetzt
jetzt präsentation weil dann muss sie an
machen sollte
mit dieser stelle danke zählt angesagter
vorschein wir mal einfach net news
stellt forscher
hallo ich habe einen randstein cocktail
gemacht das album ist deutschland
deswegen habe ich deutschland schutz
gemacht wie davor stehen schwarz rot und
gold und mit denen man sich darauf
vorbereiten kann ihr dürft durch eine
farbe aus mindestens dreier cocktail
getränk die zuschauer nicht das kann
keiner genau dazu kommt dann natürlich
noch unser basis basis getränkt dahinter
in der randstein optik typisch sieht aus
wie braun sind aber keine nazis deswegen
gut da hätte er musste erst mal sagten
ja den normalerweise tief normalerweise
weil die manieren chance mega krank
viele büro haben sind ja alles
ausgebildete pyrotechniker damit ihre
büro selber machen dürfen wir das macht
keiner mehr
doch deswegen knalls einmal ganz schön
viel uns echt ganz schön viel feuer weil
ich halt den super drauf machen weil den
kannst du normalerweise anzünden ist er
halt noch so ein bisschen nach brennt
weiß und dann im prinzip der der
feuerwehr aber das ist dann immer jetzt
mein charakter den man sich also
vorstellen vorstellen muss
ein paar ein kind brennt was man darf
sich jetzt eines aussuchen
ja und was man damit machen drücken über
war das sirup das ist sowieso
nein gut dann nehme ich den mit sirup
[Musik]
zeit nicht danach trinken dann kannst du
danach schlückchen trinken dann kann es
auch so dazu wenigstens randstein es
geht immer das ist
das kann sie das können wir alles gut
press entspannte bahnstadt man hat
warstein man hat ein bisschen angst
davor
[Musik]
und dann muss man jetzt klären warum ich
mich super lecker also ich nehme jetzt
mal ein schlückchen finde es schöner die
straßenplaner stammbuch ich frage mal
vor ich habe genug an das wirst du hier
mit karl korn haben ja das immer noch
aber nur um das ist einfach nur feuer in
seinem amt
rahmen wie kommst du denn den champagner
super dass ich champagner
das habe ich ganz vergessen also es ist
ein mix muss ich sagen aus champagner
unten und dann einen leichten schubs
sirup um die farbe zu kriegen von diesem
cola sirup also wirklich mini schuss und
dann habe ich den rest aufgefüllt mit
ginger beer was man jetzt gar nicht mehr
schmeckt und könnt ihr aufhören sich
anzugucken wenn man das erste mal hört
versteht es nicht probier mal kurz sag
mal ist das sind das ist meine randstein
cocktail das ändern die stadt direkt an
cocktail am stein oder schöner stücke
wie sieht eigentlich der apache ist ja
selber indianer und da dachte ich ich
gehe jetzt auf jeden fall nach
südamerika oder halt amerika rüber hier
sind die in jamaika und peru narnia das
ist jetzt so dass die ecke beruhen
herkunft darf man dann den schrank und
ist in peru oder um einen tag trinkt man
gerne minister und so also ins leere
weil er einfach die kecke typischen blau
wegen ging sein
dieses glas wollte ich eigentlich haben
weil das so groß ist und so unförmig
sowie apache weil jetzt doch auch so
dass gesagt ich würde sagen ja sehr für
mich aber ich habe in den drink mit
sport ja fraglich denn der beine ich
will die einfach nur so von hinten
nehmen
[Gelächter]
dennis kelly auch dabei denn sie hängt
an einem bein
das ist eigentlich mein ding das andere
ist halt so eine fun denkst ich noch
machen wollte weil ich so viel das ist
also es muss sie mit alkohol zieht bei
mir nicht mehr was er damit nicht nur
kurz darüber unterhalten deswegen
gewinnst du gerade bei mir langweilig
nur weil ich das ding so hoch nehmen
muss um zu trinken und das war schon
immer mal machen
schimmer von profis eingestellt wird
oder das ist schon
[Applaus]
sie waren noch nie gut die alte fassung
war uns immer wieder für ihren charles
darwin später bei der reichsbahn feuers
komplett du hast das nur trümmer vor
lecker lecker voll frisch von lecker das
ist für mich so gemacht denn so eine
bowle da kann also meist kommt es dass
diese eis platz nehmen wir nicht mehr
die finde ich auch lieber keine keine
bolz ist immer mein motto wie vor dem
häuser gold sache wäre schrecklich geil
da drin ja auch mit dem saft von denen
ja ja so dass allen bewusst was er von
ihm nächstes wasser kontext die bahn ja
das muss ich jetzt auch wieder erklären
ich meine basically es ist das seven
brings video da hat sie nämlich so wings
2 püschel auf dem kopf
mein gott
nico hat sie all ihre songs geschrieben
deswegen und dann ist es so dieses fancy
weil viele girls in ihren videos
mitmachen und es spielt sich alles um
girl power und alleine klar kommen und
so und jasper präsentiert das koks das
in der musikszene stets vertreten ist
und diese ihre klitoris
daran muss man auch erst mal flecken
johannes b mit einem hauch vanille und
oben ist noch dieses saure brausepulver
damit zum job bekommen und auch ein
bisschen noch resch damit es nicht so
zusammengemixt schmeckt so bisschen
zerquetschte himbeeren mit und ohne die
ja keiner wagen zu aber ihr müsst hat
wir müssen also bisschen vorsichtig
drücken weil jeder muss auch das
brausepulver bekommen weiß dass noch
zwischen gewesen wäre haben die so
richtig schön raus das hängt alles vom
bad
es geht nur für mich für meine
entscheidung gleich angespannt
also ich muss sagen ich glaube wenn
weniger für diesen glitschigen
mitzumachen sind viel besser geschmeckt
und einfach nur den champagner also mit
so einem touch anderem vanille
johannisbeere
wie die 80 besser anderen nicht so dumm
wäre die letzte folge ist der hinter
sich
da habe ich anfange zu bewerben um was
es bei mir ja das möchte ich tun soll
dann im tiebreak das hier finde ich ist
eine enttäuschung die die show fand ich
geil
das hat mir spaß gemacht da kann man
sicherlich daran arbeiten aber die idee
fand ich fantastisch das sind auswies
logo ich finde ich mir sehr viel mühe
gegeben
leider dass sein buch hat nicht
funktioniert ein bisschen over das hat
den cinque kipp davor was einfach nur
ein job mit wodka also moscow mule
deswegen wahrscheinlich lecker oder
später eine überraschung wenn ich nachts
einfach meinen bart ab dass hier finde
ich richtig weg das ist mein leben damit
ich ganz ehrlich einfach nur nach wie
vor ich kann das betonen es ist einfach
schnell ist unkompliziert es geht mir
alles was brauche und wenn ich mal
also das würde sondern denkt ans wird er
nicht betrunken und seinem zwei meter
längsten sind wir dann so dass dann
immer so
aha
weiterhin so viel zeit hat der kann
einfach so ein ding wegschütten das hier
schmeckt für mich wie wie du bist
ich weiß genau wo du hin wollte ist
damit aber 100 ich finde den ansatz
richtig gut meint es auch mit dem
brausepulver vollkommen ernst gemeint
ich finde es auch mit dem wallis novelli
ist eine geile idee das konzept finde
ich geil aber es schmeckt einfach wie
kinderpunsch weil da irgendwas drin ist
was nicht wissen was nicht so schaller
ja genau und das in das packt mich ein
bisschen ab wenn ich das im vergleich
habe weil das ist einfach eine geile
bohle ist jetzt ja nicht das beste aber
es ist von den sachen die wir gemacht
haben ist die galerie bohle genau das
konzept schmeckt besser ja genau die
konzepte sind besser als schnell eine
vase kaufen und ein schütteln und
stachelbeeren schnell herein klatschen
weil wir also noch informiert denken ja
ja also bei mir ist es leider der hier
aber nicht wegen dem konzept sondern nur
noch nicht mal wenn es konzepte wär's
kelly einmal wissen wie das kenny
schmeckt man nun ganz mit werfen jetzt
wird zum einen tick besser machen
schwöre dass ich aus wieder wieso denkt
da falle ich direkt für tun wir uns rein
ich bin dabei
jetzt hast du nur so diese aber jetzt
schmeckt man auch den champagner kalt
ich möchte nur scheinbar ja dass sie
holt mich vielmehr abmelde
das macht nur spaß einfach das ist nur
freude
[Applaus]
ich habe richtig widerlich einen hängen
jetzt gerade weil wir 19 spirituosen
durcheinander geworfen haben an denen
liegt wieder schimmert ich finde rubin
ja das ist mein ding viel besser gemacht
als ich mein geld gemacht haben
eine stunde vier aus machen ja